it's the best day of the week Friday the
day to kick back relax and not spend a
dime of your money because you don't get
paid until the next week but luckily
there's lots of awesome games right for
the picking no price tag let's start out
with the game that's got everybody
securing Charlie Ghost Recon phantoms
it's a great game if you're into
tactical cover-based shooters like Gears
of War would like a server that still
has humans in it just because it's a
rebranded Ghost Recon online doesn't
mean it's not worth a download pick from
three classes including the rugged
assault tricky recon and the athletic
supporter each class is balanced to give
them advantages and disadvantages to
each other including the assault classes
heavy armor and high health and the
recons cloaking ability which allows for
super sneaky kills with monthly weekly
and daily challenges there's always a
reason to come back including winning
one round and match each day all you
gotta do is kill a few guys they
practically fall out of the sky a good
game for a good price we can't beat it
heavy casualties inflicted no ship for
those of us who want to play trials that
are on a budget try trials frontier the
Western free-to-play version for iOS and
Android that's filled with explosive
ride through various stages gamble and
complete quests like doing a sick we
lead upgrade your bike yeah I'm good
each area to ride in costs gas and you
can run out after about a half hour a
gameplay so you might want to spend real
people money to keep riding or just get
your money's worth by riding the level
backwards than riding it again or hang
out in a part of the level for free do
this all day finally let's mix the
classic rectangular board game of
yesteryear with the technology of today
with card hunter take all the
collectible card aspects of magic the
gathering with the role player concepts
of Dungeons and Dragons and you got
yourself a good time collect cards to
build your deck pick adventures and
commence the battle move attack or cast
spells to destroy your foes and here
that amazing voice acting winning allows
you to level up and click glorious loot
the game just released a large expansion
including new features cards items and
the ever requested multiplayer mode
you'll want to get your hands on the new
elven trickery so you can convince your
foes to just get rid of all their
attacks rendering them utterly useless
and basically a punching bag a great
game that's still getting updates and
worth your time also the real world
currency is pizza and finally we're
giving you a buttload of key is to give
you exclusive items for city of steam
traverse your ways through dungeons
train cities and other greedy locations
slashing monsters that are in your way
to complete quests and level up skills
in a pack that gives you a bunch of
hopeful resources and cosmetic items to
make you look your steampunky self just
click the link below this video to grab
a code for yourself that's all for this
episode but I'll be back with more free
games next Friday see ya